foreign
I think it's safe to say there's never
been a moment like this one
in all of history
of course it's always safe to say that
because every moment is unique and can
never be reproduced
but when it comes to AI the changes
we've seen
in a single generation and lately in a
single day
are truly historically novel
we are the first human beings to ever
experience this
I want to talk about how we experience
it
AI is changing how we work and create
it's helping us solve complex problems
in ecology
urban planning and Medicine
from diagnosing disease to detecting
forest fires
AI is giving us a new view of our planet
and ourselves this comes with challenges
there are ongoing debates and open
questions about ethics
power
and the relationships between humans and
machines
are we at risk of losing what makes us
most human
how can we preserve and even enhance the
best in ourselves with AI
I think the answer to these questions
lies in three principles
creation
collaboration and care
creation collaboration and care
we need to nurture creative
relationships with AI
I've written with AI on several projects
and as an author I've seen firsthand how
AI co-writing can open the mind with
remarkable results
to test these ideas I wrote a novel with
gpt3
the AI suggested synchronistic plot
twists
penetrating character arcs and critical
perspectives I wouldn't have thought of
on my own
together we created something more
compelling and imaginative than either
of us would have a loan
so let's co-create with AI I love
collaborations because collaborations
are more than the sum of their parts
for almost 10 years I've been bringing
artists and philosophers in to work with
researchers at Google AI through the
artists and machine intelligence program
by collaborating with machines we've
encouraged a new form of Art
that combines and transforms photography
poetry Cinema and music with machine
learning models
but we've also brought the critical and
creative imaginations of artists into
the process of developing AI
if we want a world that preserves and
enhances
the best parts of Being Human we need a
wide range of voices and disciplines
present in the process of making AI
so let's collaborate on making AI
AI needs a goal it needs a North star
I believe the highest purpose for AI is
to be healing
that's why I created the Opera song of
the ambassadors working with
neuroscientists to study the effects of
music and human AI feedback loops
by integrating AI generated brainwave
imagery into the performance we were
able to propose
new musical and therapeutic approaches
song of the ambassadors is offered as a
prototype for a new kind of art that
turns our highest technology towards
Collective healing
so let's care for each other with AI
these principles are simple
they might seem obvious
but the world is changing fast and AI is
complex
so the point needs to be made clearly
AI should preserve and enhance the best
parts of Being Human
but first we must imagine new
possibilities and new narratives for our
future together
next time you're thinking about or even
thinking with AI
look for opportunities to create
collaborate and care
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
trunks of sure
are you your countless faces
rise to admire your countless faces
faces faces faces faces faces
[Music]
facing to the space without limit in
which our words
[Music]
I see
this
[Music]
time is
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]